bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir on vient de
fermer la porte à voir clairement votre
réaction d'abord monsieur cadieux ça a
été confirmé en fin d'après-midi
ben en fait c'est une information des
services frontaliers canadiens
hier soir ce sont les médias m'ont
alertée vers 21h qu'une exemption est
aimée du communiqué
fourni
oui en soi mais j'ai juste soir à 21h ma
réaction envers les minorités
approximativement à cette heure là et
pour apprendre ce matin au réveil que il
n'en était pas question que transports
canada
maintenait le 15 janvier prochain alors
de l'homme aurait agi ces assos se
maintient à partir de samedi d'une
obligation vaccinale pour les
camionneurs en fait on avait quand même
tenté de sensibiliser le gouvernement
verdict est moins
démontré qu'ils auraient des impacts
importants sur l'économie sur les
échanges commerciaux
notre industrie étant dans un bien
d'autres milieux dans une un moment de
stress n'avait pas besoin de confusion
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est un crée
évidemment un tumulte toute la journée
aujourd'hui il ya combien trop d'honneur
qui ne sont pas adéquatement vacciner
écoutez le gouverneur canada 105 pour ça
mais on m'a demandé d'où venaient les
chiffres les autres j'avais eu
combien nous être le volant à 2 5% nous
nous estimons à peu près entre 10 et 15%
alors que nous sommes nous sommes le
miroir de la société en général pas
différent de ce qui se passe au québec
le québec est quand même une province
plus vaccinée donc c'est peut-être cette
chance mais le reste du canada
les chiffres de son poleman hockey quels
seront les effets après voir madame prou
sur l'économie
il un pack seront énormes mais
j'aimerais dire que nous on est on est
frustré on est déçu de voir que le
gouvernement fédéral est revenu sur sa
décision pour contrainte qu'elle
chacun c'est notre principal partenaire
commercial alors par camion annuellement
en échange d'environ 450 milliards par
année c'est énorme alors juste pour se
donner un ordre de grandeur à partir de
samedi mais ce sont quatre camions sur
10 4 camions sur deux américains du nord
pourront plus rentrer au canada parce
que le taux de vaccination aux états
unis est de 60% en plus s'attendre à ce
que ce soit la même chose chez les
camionneurs à me fier alors quatre
camions sur dix est énorme ça va être
énorme pour les manufacturiers ce qui
veut dire qu'il va y avoir des pertes
économiques des délais importants puis
ultime en baisse à sera refilée aux
consommateurs ce qui veut dire que
l'augmentation de coûts est refilée aux
consommateurs et vous savez c'est très
difficile de trouver plusieurs produits
sur les tablettes mais ce sera encore
plus difficile pour les québécois
d'accéder à certains produits dont des
glissements ciel mais en même temps le
gouvernement madame prou annoncé ça au
mois de novembre comment se fait-il
qu'on arrive aujourd'hui qu'on soit
étonné et qu'on a et qu'on entre dans
des scénarios catastrophe le christ est
hélas canada catastrophe depuis que
cette annonce et ça fait depuis le mois
d'octobre on échange sur le sujet avec
le gouvernement fédéral il n'y avait
aucune ouverture
c'était vraiment la ligne du riarc on
entendu cette annonce on s'est dit bon
une certaine ouverture ils comprennent
que ça n'a pas de sens de mettre une
barrière au commerce houssin partante
parce que c'est une barrière au commerce
si les camionneurs canadien se verse ni
à 80 85 % mais c'est quand même un
camion ou deux sur dix qui ne pourront
pas traverser la frontière et encore une
fois l'on parle de produits
agroalimentaires de biens essentiels des
biens d'un secteur la défense vraiment
chez tous les secteurs d'activité et les
mecs catholiques sont pris au piège dans
cette situation c'est quoi les solutions
à partir de maintenant monsieur cadieux
résolution c'est de tenter de faire ce
qu'on pouvant avec la main d'oeuvre que
nous aurons de jour en jour j'apprends
beaucoup plus d'absentéisme on sait que
le 20 mia actuels auront peut-être dans
pour les non verts pour les verts s'il
est moins malade mais n'empêche qu'il ya
le beaucoup plus d'absentéisme en ce
moment et je dois je dois ajouter la
parole de véronique nous tentons à notre
demande de délai d'avoir le plus haut de
vaccination on n'essaie pas de se
soustraire à la vaccination exemple dans
d'autres milieux devant la est obligé de
reculer parce que la réalité était un
mur alors
je pars me vaut vraiment parmi les
camionneurs est ce qu'un enjeu avec la
vaccination est ce que vous sentez de la
résistance
parmi les camionneurs
nous sommes le reflet et en général à
une hauteur des gens qui sont carrément
contre la vaccination d'autres qui
craignaient la vaccination et on sait
que ce qu'on entend de la santé publique
on est passé de 1500 à 6000 les accès
deux premiers vaccins par jour en ce
moment la santé publique on est certain
qu'on a un pourcentage ces gens là mais
faut nous donner un peu de temps pour
s'y rendre les quand les autorités
gouvernementales ne vous explique ou
disent dans leur communiqué qu'ils ont
acquise on nous ont informés au cours de
la journée de la situation au moment où
je vous parle ou en direct il n'y a
aucune autorité gouvernementale
canadienne qui a communiqué avec nous
nous sommes le québec la province
voisine des états unis est ce que madame
proulx il est clair pour vous que la
solution pour les manufacturiers c'est
d'augmenter les coûts pour les
consommateurs
dans cette fois la solution parce que
même s'il y aura une augmentation coup
nécessairement parce que bon les
transporteurs en moins de capacités vont
chercher davantage aux manufacturiers
mais il va quand même avoir une injure
de capacités c'est à dire qu'il ya
plusieurs pme qui n'arriveront pas
trouvé les camions dont ils ont besoin
soit pour exporter ou pour importer
alors nous sommes demandé un délai pour
permettre un plus haut taux de
vaccination ultime ans qu'on demande au
gouvernement fédéral d'avoir un plan et
les le plan pour les mêmes facturier
qu'ils vont venir ce jusqu'à qu'un ce
serait quoi le bon de l'eau dans un
premier temps me demandait 1 3 mois pour
permettre de travailler avec les parties
prenantes voir comment on peut aussi le
taux de vaccination ultime ans on
représente les manufacturiers puis je
réitère
il faut être pragmatique on est pour la
vaccination on a contribué aux efforts
de vaccination québec multidanse hélas
un certain pourcentage qui ne sont pas
vaccinés ça ne fait aucun sens de
prendre prendre au piège les
manufacturiers éventuellement que les
consignes mais alors ça ça rit ça rentre
en vigueur donc de toute évidence à moi
qu'il faut changement dans des 48
prochaines heures monsieur cadieux
madame pro merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit